>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Rob Casper: Hi, everybody.
How are you doing?
>> Good.
>> Great.
>> Rob Casper: Welcome to
the National Book Festival.
My name is Rob Casper.
I'm the head of the Poetry and
Literature Center at the library.
You guys are the last big group
before we go into the evening.
We're happy to have you here at
the Poetry and Press Pavilion.
I want to thank the cochairman of
the festival, David Rubenstein,
and the many National
Book Festival sponsors
who made this possible this year.
Also, I want to thank those who
supported it year after year.
Chief among them, The National
Endowment for the Arts,
that that helps make
this pavilion possible.
They're all in the back.
You can check out their materials.
It's give them a big hand.
[ Applause ]
You, too, can support the
festival with a gift of a donation
by checking the information in the
festival program and on the app.
We welcome your help in making
the festival possible next year
and every year.
The festival would not be
possible without the support
of sponsors and booklovers.
Two other housekeeping
items I have to add.
First, if you could
silence your cell phones
or any electronic devices
that might interfere
with the recording of this event.
Second, if there is a Q&A session,
and the mics are on either side,
don't worry about [inaudible].
Mics are on either side.
You can come up and ask
questions, but if you do,
know that this event
is being recorded,
and you will be part
of the recording.
So I realized that
there's no podium now.
So I could do a very Juan
Felipesque kind of thing and,
you know, do my little dance.
How lucky we are today to have Juan
Felipe Herrera here in conversation.
I have such love for our 21st Poet
Laureate Consultant in poetry,
though I'm still recovering
from trying to keep up with him.
And you'll see, you understand
that more as the hour goes on.
Juan Felipe was, arguably, the most
active poet to accept the position
with two projects in his first
term and three in his second,
and just for a point
of reference, usually,
we let a poet laureate
have one project
in the second term, not five total.
But what projects they were.
My personal favorite title
is The Technicolor Adventures
of Catalina Neon, though
I am probably proudest
of Word Street Champions and
Brave Builders of the Dream.
Yeah, even looking at it now,
I think, those are impressive.
I could say more about them and
Juan Felipe's tenure as laureate,
but I'll leave that to our
moderator, Anya Creightney,
the program's manager
at the library's Poetry
and Literature Center, and
a fellow poetry visionary.
But let me just say
that Juan Felipe is one
of the most life-affirming
people I have ever known.
He continues to inspire me with
his enthusiasm, his sincerity,
his openness and generosity, and his
but dazzling creativity,
I know I'm not alone.
Please join me in welcoming Juan
Felipe Hererra and Anya Creightney.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney: Thank you so
much, Ron, for that introduction,
and thank you all for being here.
Welcome to the 2017
National Book Festival.
At least the tail end of it anyway.
So I thought we'd start in an
unusual place, since it's the end
of the day, and many of
us have been here all day.
I thought that maybe
we start with a poem,
if that's all right with you all.
Maybe Juan Felipe can
read us a poem.
[ Applause ]
And then we can get
into it, all right?
So I chose this poem, Juan Felipe,
because you wrote it during your
term as poet laureate and first
and foremost, it's fun, like you.
So will you read it for us?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay.
>> Anya Creightney: Okay.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Sure, thank you.
>> Anya Creightney: You're welcome.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: To
be here, and thank you, Anya.
>> Anya Creightney: My pleasure.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Thank you so much, and Rob,
thank you so much once again.
Library of Congress and everyone
right here, muchos gracias.
Thanks everybody.
Well, no, I use to -- my
uncle used to love boxing back
in the early days in Southern
California and San Diego.
It was a big old, brutal coliseum a
few blocks down from where we lived
on C Street, and all the
wrestlers were out there, you know,
and the boxers and Sweet Pea Johnson
and Mexican boxers and que Dynamite
and [Spanish name given].
Those cool guys slugging it
out with peanut shells flying
out of the bleachers.
That was also, those were the years
of Sonny Liston and Cassius Clay,
who became Mohammed
Ali, who I loved.
And so this poem, then it, is
titled You Can't Put Mohammed Ali
in a Poem.
Because, you know, he passed away
not too long ago, and I just had
to write a poem for him, but
then I thought in a split second,
you can't put Mohammed Ali --
there's no way you
can put him in a poem.
He's just too big, too powerful.
So this is it, and so let's
do this together, by the way,
since we're starting off.
>> Anya Creightney: Let's do it.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
it's been a beautiful day,
and you have beautiful hearts,
and you do beautiful
things for so many people.
So let's all say -- let's just say
the title to get the ball rolling.
Everyone say, "You can't."
>> [audience] You can't.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Put Mohammed Ali.
>> [audience] Put Mohammed Ali.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: In a poem.
>> [audience] In a poem.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: If you did.
>> [audience] If you did.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: It would.
>> [audience] It would.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Knock you down.
>> [audience] Knock you down.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Remember Sonny Liston?
>> [audience] Remember Sonny Liston?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And.
>> [audience] And.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: If.
>> [audience] If.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: You were.
>> [audience] You were.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Still standing.
>> [audience] Still standing.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: You would.
>> [audience] You would.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Have to.
>> [audience] Have to.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Bust out.
>> [audience] Bust out.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Remember the march in Washington?
>> [audience] Remember
the march in Washington?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Bust out of your shaken,
vaulted, poor thinking self.
>> [audience] Bust out of your
shaken, vaulted, poor thinking self.
>> Juan Filipe Herrera: Oh, yes.
>> [audience] Oh, yes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And change.
>> [audience] And change.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> [audience] That's right.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
This big old world.
>> [audience] This big old world.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
This big old world.
>> [audience] This big old world.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Say it.
>> [audience] Say it.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
This big old world.
>> [audience] This big old world.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And if.
>> [audience] And if.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: You did.
>> [audience]: You did.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: You.
>> [audience]: You.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes you.
>> [audience]: Yes you.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Would have to battle.
>> [audience]: Would have to battle.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Battle with
words and rhymes and body and time.
>> [audience]: Battle with words
and rhymes and body and time.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: For.
>> [audience]: For.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Your new.
>> [audience]: Your new.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Idea.
>> [audience]: Idea.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Did you hear that?
>> [audience]: Did you hear that?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: You would.
>> [audience]: You would.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Have to.
>> [audience]: Have to.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Endure.
>> [audience]: Endure.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I hear you.
>> [audience]: I hear you.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And propose.
>> [audience]: And propose.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: What?
>> [audience]: What?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: A new name.
>> [audience]: A new name.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: For.
>> [audience]: For.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: All.
>> [audience]: All.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: A new name.
>> [audience]: A new name.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
It could be peace.
>> [audience]: It could be peace.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
It could be unity.
>> [audience]: It could be unity.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Sounds easy.
>> [audience]: Sounds easy.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: But.
>> [audience]: But.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: This poem.
>> [audience]: This poem.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Cannot.
>> [audience]: Cannot.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Provide.
>> [audience]: Provide.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: This.
>> [audience]: This.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Or contain.
>> [audience]: Or contain.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: This.
>> [audience]: This.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Word.
>> [audience]: Word.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Watch out.
>> [audience]: Watch out.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Here it comes.
>> [audience]: Here it comes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Here comes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And.
>> [audience]: And.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: It's.
>> [audience]: It's.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Gonna.
>> [audience]: Gonna.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Sting.
>> [audience]: Sting.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Like a.
>> [audience]: Like a.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Bee.
>> [audience]: Bee.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: You see?
We didn't put Mohammed
Ali in the poem.
We didn't put them in the poem.
>> Anya Creightney: That's right.
That's why love that poem.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah, yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: He
ends up with a poem.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
you have Mohammed Ali now.
You have Mohammed Ali.
>> Anya Creightney: Well, I told
you he was lively and fun, didn't I?
>> [audience]: Yes.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney: So we're
here to talk a little bit,
reflect a little bit anyway, about
your term as US Poet Laureate,
your two terms, from 2015 to 2017,
and all of you know him as Laureate,
but for those who don't know, he was
first appointed by former Librarian
of Congress, James H. Billington,
and then reappointed in 2016.
It was a special time
for the library,
and inside of those two
years, you did a lot.
Rob alluded to all of what you did.
You kept us running
there in the office,
and you kept us dazzling ourselves.
So I thought we could talk a
little bit, but person going
to remind you all of
some what you did.
Are you ready for your list
of what you, yourself, did?
So you traveled to hundreds
of universities, colleges,
community centers, elementary
schools, festivals, and libraries.
You watched not one but
five Laureate projects,
all of which extended your
particular vision of poetry.
You collected four
honorary doctorates,
the Robert Kirsch Lifetime
Achievement Award from the LA Times.
And outstanding Latino and
Cultural Award in Literary Arts
and Publications from
the American Association
of Hispanics in Higher Education.
You gave a slew of commencement
addresses, too many interviews
to list, and you wrote one
YA book, one children's book,
and two board books, and you
said, half a poetry collection.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Right, yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: So can we have a
round of applause for all that work?
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you,
Anya, and you know, and everyone,
you know, the thing is, the
inspiration comes from people,
and the inspiration comes from
when people let me know, you know,
their stories and where they're
coming form and how they feel
about these last couple of years.
In particular, last two years,
and I do all this for everyone.
I do all this for everyone, and
the doctorates are for everyone.
So that's what that's about.
You know? If it was for me,
I would probably be just
walking my dog, you know?
I'd be walking my dog.
But this is for you.
It for you.
It's not for me.
>> Anya Creightney:
I somehow doubt that.
But I want to go back
to the beginning.
Can you tell me what you
remember about the time, you know,
that specific time when
you were first appointed?
What most excited you
or intimidated you.
It was a big moment.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's a big moment.
>> Anya Creightney:
Big lifetime moment.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I
think it was just the change.
You know, when you hit change in the
face, when it hits you in the face,
there really is nothing to
say, because you write in it,
and there's few words to express
what you're going through.
I didn't have any words to
express what I was going through.
Rob Casper said, "Juan Felipe,
your laugh is going to change.
It's going to change, one Felipe.
Come on. Are you excited?"
And I was just standing
there like a mummy.
I would like a mummy
because it was so big,
and I couldn't come
up with any words.
I like -- I believe Rob.
I said how's it going to change?
I changed a lot of things.
I'm already done changing.
I went through the changes
already, but he was right.
Little by little, a tsunami grew,
and all the people that I met,
and everything that they told me
and what I saw them go through,
and what they were going through,
it just added a lot of force
to the tsunami of their humanity, of
our humanity, and there were so much
that I couldn't contain
myself after two years.
After two years, I
literally was scorched.
I literally was scorched, and I
didn't know what to do with all
that fire in me, and all
the feelings and emotions
that were expressed to me
from high schoolers, elders,
those that were running from ICE.
Students that were crying, because
of how they felt about the election.
Students, young people, that
said they believed in peace.
That they wanted a life of
peace, and on and on and on.
They said, "Juan Felipe, we
came all the way from Racine,
and we know that you're going
to be in Milwaukee tonight.
So we came from Racine, and we're
really excited, because we want
to hear about we are
interested in climate change.
Because we are interested
in climate change."
And you know, that's how it was.
I said, well, you know
what, put away my poetry.
Let's talk about climate change.
That's what happened.
People were interested in coming
together, and poetry was okay,
but they really wanted
to be together.
They were so concerned
about so many things.
So that's where the change started
really brewing, and it just kept
on moving until the
very end and now.
>> Anya Creightney: It sounds
like you're describing
yourself as a vessel.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes.
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, a sort of vessel.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: That's true.
>> Anya Creightney: So you've
talked a lot about the humanity
and the doctorates, for example,
you said are for everyone else.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
They're for everyone.
>> Anya Creightney:
They're for everyone else.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: That's it.
>> Anya Creightney: So this is
something I think is something you
believe substantially, and
it's what makes you you,
and I think you think poetry should
be an inclusive space and full
of not just truth but tenderness.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes.
>> Anya Creightney: And not
just community but also craft.
So I want you to talk a little bit
about your vision and this idea
of inclusivity and how that
relates to your idea of poetry.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay.
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, that space.
That special space.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: All
right, I'll give it a go.
You know, when we began -- when
I began, it was in the late 60s.
Well, actually, in high
school, when I was a junior,
and then when I hit
UCLA in '67 on an EOP,
affirmative-action
economic opportunity grant,
that the only way I could be there,
and that was the time, as you know,
of the Vietnam war and all the fire
around it, and that was the time,
as you know, all the
movements came to a boil.
The women's movement.
You name it.
The gay/lesbian movement.
The black power movement.
The red power movement.
Yellow power.
All the colors of power.
They came to a peak.
You know, [Spanish spoken],
the international linkages
with Latin America, Mexico,
and beyond, came to a peak.
So that it was about
coming together.
In my case, this was a
perfect moment for me
because I could stand
up on a stage and speak.
And recite.
I had been working on
it since twelfth grade,
because I was so afraid to speak,
I said I don't want
to be afraid to speak.
I want to be able to tell the truth.
I'm afraid to tell the truth.
I don't want to be afraid anymore.
So I began to train
myself and inquire --
just come out and throw my voice
out there, as afraid as I was.
So '67 and '68 is when the stage
appeared, and I can actually get
up there and try my voice out,
and it was about tenderness,
and it was about kindness, because
it was about gathering our peoples,
and it was about embracing
our lives,
it was about healing our communities
with as much as we could provide.
Whether it was information.
Whether it was music,
poetry, cultural knowledge,
historical awareness, ways to
organize, all those were embraces,
and all that was kindness.
And of course, we had to deal with
police brutality, and of course,
we had to deal with issues
of war and peace and issues
of power all at the same time.
But I began that way,
and with a guitar,
and 7-foot-long hair and tunics.
I wore a Mayan tunic, Tenajapa,
woven in Tenajapa Chapas.
So that's how I began.
So kindness for me
as an integral part.
It's hard to get in touch with
kindness, because, in my case,
these days, I'm getting really
angry, and I don't like to be angry.
But it's just kind of pouring out
of me, and I have to just work it.
I have to work it out and
breathe and stretch and meditate,
and write it out and
talk it out a bit.
The idea is kindness.
And that's, perhaps, the only way
we can make things work the way they
need to happen.
And also, facing our fears
and confronting the issues
that are taking place
at the same time,
like we just said, with tenderness.
And poetry, then, we have to open
it up so it could be all colors,
all languages, all classes,
and find ways to write it
in a different manner
and use all manners.
You know, I started with one
hand, which was as a street poet,
as a spoken word poet, a
bilingual poet, a self-made poet,
a community poet, and you
all make the tortillas.
You know, you all make
the poetry together.
There really is no workshop.
The workshop is your community,
and then much later, when I was 40,
I went to the writers' workshop.
So then I had two hands.
I had the spoken word
community hand,
self-made poetry are the stages,
in the rallies, and the marches,
and then with the workshop,
then a friend of mine said,
what you come to the workshop?
The writers workshop?
I go, what is that?
What is that?
I've never heard of it.
He goes, that's where
people come around a table
and read poetry to each other.
All, I said, I can do that.
That's not going to
be a problem at all.
So I applied, and I got in.
So then I learned a number of
things, another set of writers,
another set of history,
word histories
of writers, and also, new tools.
So I had two hands now where I
could make a really big tortilla.
So I'm happy about that.
So that's when you start messing
with your stanzas and lines
and have a great time, as well is
saying things that need to be said.
So that's how it is, and we need
to really let our voices come in.
It's good to honor all our poetry,
but we're missing a lot of poetry.
We're missing a lot of poetry.
So we need to open the doors
for writers from all countries,
because they're writing
great material.
I had an interview with the
Excelsior from Mexico City,
and one of the first
things the reporter said
from the Excelsior,
biggest newspaper.
He said, "Well, now that
you're [Spanish spoken]."
He said, now that you're the
laureate of the United States,
what are you going to do to bring
Mexican poets to the United States?
Well, uh, if I was in the
travel business, we could do it,
but the real -- it
was a good question.
You know, we do a lot of poetry,
and we have a lot of issues to deal
with it too, then open it up, and
get it out without too many hurdles.
There's a lot of hurdles sometimes.
>> Anya Creightney:
A lot of hurdles.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: You
know, there's a lot of steps
to go through, and we
must open it up, really.
Open up the road, but then again,
we have to also open up the pathway
for our international
and global writers.
>> Anya Creightney: What do we gain?
I know it's perhaps
obvious question,
but I think it bears repeating.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
What do we gain from --
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, when we gain?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
From Singapore and China?
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And from Africa?
>> Anya Creightney: What do we gain?
What do we all gain in our --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
from Mexico and from Cuba?
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, all over the world.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Well, we
gain voices that we have not heard,
and we're going to be surprised,
because people are
saying things differently,
and they're so different, that we
become a little too complicated.
That's one of the things
that I picked.
I said, gosh, who got
complicated in my writing?
I sure got all my stuff all tangled
up, and people are just saying it,
and that's great, and also
doing all the other things,
you know, complex things.
That's okay, but they're
very direct,
and I just like to hear
voices from the world,
and I want to hear more voices from
Brazil, more voices from Africa,
from Lithuania, where everybody
in Lithuania knows poetry,
and like that, you
know, where people --
I was having some kind of food
with Margarita, my partner,
in San Diego, in Old Town.
I live in San Diego Barrio, Logan
Heights, and I went to Old Town
because Old Town, it was kind
of like a tourist area,
but it's okay, you know?
Let's just go to Old Town.
So I was in Old Town.
A woman that was serving, you know,
the food and her partner, friend,
for some reason we
got in a conversation
about the great Turkish
poet, Nazim Hikmet.
I do know how that
happened, and they said,
"Oh, you know Nazim Hikmet?"
I go, well, a little bit.
"We love Nizem Hikmet.
We know all his poetry.
And in Turkey, we all
know Nizim Hikmet."
I go, I should have known.
You know? Because in Turkey,
everybody knows Nizim Hikmet,
and people here from that
country know Nizim Hikmet,
who was a great poet, was a great
poet, and same thing with Korea.
You know, I'm hanging out.
I don't know how I got into it talk
about Ko Un, a great Korean poet,
and I was talking with
a Korean student,
and he goes, "You know Ko Un?"
I go yeah.
"Wow, everyone in Korea knows
Ko Un, and you know Ko Un."
Yeah, he's great.
Well, okay.
Yeah, let's have a
conversation, you know?
Wow. You know, kind of
rebel Buddhist monk outside
of the -- what is it?
Outside of the what?
Outside of the box?
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, stratosphere.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Korean, Buddhist.
He was here.
>> Anya Creightney: He was at
the Library of Congress, yes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Amazing
poet who wrote how many thousands
of poems about people that he met.
How many? What's the number?
10,000?
>> Anya Creightney: Yep.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thousands.
He said one day, today,
I'm going to write a poem
about everybody that I know.
And he wrote like 12 volumes.
>> Anya Creightney: I
guess, mm-hm, you'd have to.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Twelve volumes, thousands,
and that's just one
project Ko Un did.
And I like him.
He's a lot of fun.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: So I like
it when I hear about other poets,
and that's how I learned about him.
I learned by having conversations.
>> Anya Creightney:
Presumably, you also learn
about yourself in the same way.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I was kind
of challenged to learn about myself.
I was challenged to
learn about myself.
I was reading Basho on the plane
over here, the great Japanese poet.
He was born in 611, and he talks --
he has diaries with haikus so
you're reading these diaries.
He has these journeys, right?
You, through Japan, Tokyo,
outside of Tokyo, Kyoto back then.
And he talks about just
walking and writing,
and the most precious thing is to
notice the moon, and that's it.
That's it.
The most precious thing is to
notice the moon and the moonlight,
and he also meets people
along the way,
but he talks about
a lot of big things.
And he talks about how he met a
little, tiny girl on the road.
This was hard to read, and he said,
-- he says someone must've left her.
Her parents must have abandoned
her here by the river, and he says,
"I gave her the food I had."
He says, "But I noticed that
a greater force had put her
in this predicament,
and I had to go on."
And that's hard for me to read.
Because I'm kind of a rescue guy.
I'm a big rescue guy.
I carry cookies to feed
the sparrows outside.
>> Anya Creightney:
You did it today.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
So I was reading Basho,
and I really enjoy reading
him because of what he said
about being a poet, and
how times have changed now.
You know, walking, we don't
really think about walking
or noticing what he called nature.
It's kind of secondary
may be or tertiary,
or maybe not even on our list.
We're just walking and working
like Malcolm Margolin said,
a great publisher in the Bay
Area, who founded Hey Day Books.
And we went to have a dinner after
reading on the Laureate Road.
He goes, "Let's go
have dinner, Juan."
I said okay.
And then he said, "Juan."
I go, yes, Malcolm?
"What happened to recess?
[ Laughing ]
What happened to magic, Juan?"
And just like Basho,
you know, the moon.
What happened to the moon?
What happened to recess?
What happened to magic?"
I know that sounds
unexpected, maybe, to you.
But he hit me hard.
I go, yeah.
What happened to recess?
I'm writing nonstop
like a poetry machine.
I said, why am I doing this?
Why do I have to become
a poetry machine?
And I meet my friends.
"Hey, Juan.
So what's your new book, Juan?"
You know, I've got a
new book I'm doing now.
You know, I want to send it
out, and then I'm going to work.
You know? I go, that's okay.
But when I think about
Basho and I think
about Malcolm, something's
not right.
Something's not right.
So it's good to meet
people and listen
to them, and reevaluate myself.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: Well, speaking
of reevaluation and reflection,
I'd be remiss if we
didn't talk a little bit
about these many poet
Laureate projects.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay.
>> Anya Creightney: I wonder if we
can talk a little bit about them.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay.
>> Anya Creightney: I'll
give the audience just a peek
into what you -- how
you kept us so busy.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay.
>> Anya Creightney: We had, in your
first year, La Casa de Colores,
which was really two
objects boiled into one,
a crowd sourced poem revolving --
or with revolving themes
of your choosing,
and then a short video installation
where you discussed specific items
from the collection of
Library of Congress,
and then in the second
year, you had what rob was ,
the Word Street Champions and
The Brave Builders of the Dream,
a joint project with the
Chicago Public Schools District,
the fourth largest school
district in the country.
The Poetry Foundation, of
course, the Library of Congress,
in which basically a pilot
enrichment program for teachers
to bring poetry into
the school curriculum,
and then you had The Technicolor
Adventures of Catalina Neon,
which ultimately yielded a
children's book with pictures
from a local illustrator
named Juana Mendina,
and the whole book was intended
for second and third graders.
And last, but certainly not
least, you had The Laureate Lab,
which was a creative, multi-used
space at Fresno State University,
California, promoting artistic
expression and play and fun,
everything that's Juan Felipe.
So I wonder, of that massive
list that just going so much,
maybe you want to pick one and talk
a little bit about what it meant
to you, either The
Word Street Champions.
These for all second-year projects,
either Word Street Champions
or Cata, Cata Neon, as we came
to call her in the office,
that was so special to all of us.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Well,
you know, I want to thank you
and Anne Holmes, and I
want to thank Rob Casper.
If it wasn't for the staff and
Ron egging me on to keep on going
and never said no, and I said to
myself, well, if he hasn't said no,
I just want to keep on going.
But you know, having such great
creative support of a people
at the Library of Congress and the
Poetry Center and Literature Center,
I wouldn't have probably
done only one-tenth of that.
So I just kept on going.
For me, all of those projects have
to do with what we started with,
in my generation, in the 60s,
with opening up the access
for the people, access
for the people.
So access for the people,
validating their culture,
validating their language,
validating their experience,
validating them as human beings to
fully express themselves, to create,
and to build a new society from the
center of where they're coming from,
and that's how I started, and
that's what the laureateship
and the department
and Rob and yourself
and Anne assisted me in doing.
So that's what it was all about,
and it was all about, also,
creating a public presence.
Where we do not --
where we're not speaking
or we don't have any channels or
our channels are cut off, severed,
or choked, then we become
silent and invisible,
even though we don't
want to be silent.
We want to write.
We want to speak, but
the forums are not there,
or the forums are kept away or
banned from our use, in one way
or another, or a language is
not available in our schools,
or the reading is not available,
or the books are not available.
So what do you do?
What you do is you
promote people's voices.
What you do is you create a
project where the students,
second and third year, can write
their book, and we're going
to put it up at the Library of
Congress for the whole world to see.
So it will be made public.
So it will have presence.
So it won't be invisible, and
the children will not be silent,
and when we went to
Chicago, and Rob Casper.
And the children will not be
silent, and when we went to Chicago,
and Rob Casper was instrumental in
making that project become reality.
We worked with 40 school districts.
Not one, not two, 40,
and 40 teachers representing those
districts at the Poetry Foundation.
Rob Casper put together the
support system and our department,
put it together, making sure it
was well-oiled and kept on going,
and Don Share, the people at The
Poetry Foundation supported it.
So we had the support system,
and the teachers had a budget,
and it came together, and why?
So they could have materials,
creative poetry ideas,
and exercises for their students
who do not have enough materials
or enough exercises and approaches
to expressing themselves,
in order to tell their stories
and have their voices heard,
to make it heard, to make it public,
to make their faces
present everywhere
and those 40 school districts.
So it's that same idea.
[ Applause ]
That's what it is.
And that's the way all
those projects work.
And the Catalina Neon
was a lot of fun.
>> Anya Creightney: It was fun.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Because we
had second graders, second graders?
>> Anya Creightney:
Second and third.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Second
and third graders submitting ideas
on how to write the story of
Catalina and her dog, Tortilla,
who jumps over the
fence and gets lost,
and they decided where
it got lost too.
They decided to take the doggie
under a big, old, underground
tunnel.
So then I had to go down
there, and then they decided
to create a magic dome
of the library.
So they went to the magic
dome, and then they wanted
to throw space carrot
beings into it.
So we had some space carrot beings.
And they were in there, and all
of the sudden, we ended up --
I don't want to mess the book
for you, because it's online.
They ended up in outer space.
Like Catalina and dog, Tortilla,
surfing on a magical
skateboard to the Earth.
So that was cool, don't you think?
Yeah? Second grade and third
graders working with their teachers
and librarian from various
places in the United States,
and the book's up online.
It's online.
>> Anya Creightney: At read.gov.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
Juana Medina illustrated it,
who's an artist here in
DC, and on and on, huh?
Did we miss something?
Did I miss something?
>> Anya Creightney: No,
no, that was fabulous.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah, yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay.
>> Anya Creightney:
But it was fun also
because Cata Neon began
as a sort of riff.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Oh, it was a riff.
>> Anya Creightney: In the audience
-- or, I'm sorry, in the office
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: It did.
>> Anya Creightney: And
we just went from there.
Which is so Juan Felipe.
It's nonlinear and fabulous.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: That's it.
We're going to give
you a little workshop.
So this is how it's done, okay?
Okay? I know you're all writing
ideas and have books cooking.
So here it is.
Here it is.
So anyway, I said, hey, Rob.
Because they were like
my writing team.
They used to be, you
know, they had other jobs,
but they became a writing team.
You know, like screenwriters?
They became my screenwriters.
So I said, I said, hey, Rob.
We're going to do something,
a children's book,
written by young people, and
we're going to call it --
we're going to call it -- how about
we use the word Catalina, Catalina.
He goes, "Yeah, okay."
Then I went to Anya.
I said, Anya, the title has the
title has the word Catalina,
Catalina in it, but,
you know, come on.
You know, throw something at me.
Throw something at me,
and then you said --
>> Anya Creightney: Neon.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And then she said neon.
I said, perfect!
Catalina Neon.
Yeah! Yeah!
That's it, yeah!
So then I went to Rob's office.
Hey, Rob, you know, we've got it.
We've got it.
Catalina Neon, Rob.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
But it needs a little
bit, one more thing.
One more little spice.
Just one more spice.
Give me some spice.
And then Rob said, "Oh,
The Technicolor Adventures
of Catalina Neon."
I go, that's it!
So that's how we did it.
So working in groups is a good idea.
How many of you work in groups,
have groups that you work with?
Beautiful.
A hand for the group workers.
[ Applause ]
And how many of you like
to write here and there?
A little bit?
Good, a big hand for the
writers, big hand for the writers.
And how many of you are teachers?
You're teachers, you like to teach.
A big hand for the teachers.
>> Anya Creightney: A big
hand for the teachers.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
how they are librarians?
Librarians.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, I love librarians.
I love libraries.
I used to love libraries
because they look better
than my little house, my little
apartment room in San Diego
on 9th Street, because
they were big.
They had a lot of nice tables.
So big hand for librarians, and
a big hand for everybody else.
Everybody else, too.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney:
It's equal opportunity.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah,
it's what you've got to do.
So that's how you can do it.
Just like that.
You get one word.
That's all you need.
Some of you go, oh, I
don't have the idea.
I need to have the idea
for the whole book.
Let's see, the first
chapter, second chapter,
and then the breaking point, the
climax, and the end, surprise.
The last word and the first
sentence has to be like the opener,
and somewhere in there, you
have to do like a breaking,
and excite people and, okay,
all you need is one word.
Just one word.
Everybody come up with
one word, okay?
Five seconds, okay?
Just one word, okay?
I want to count to three.
Don't think about it.
Just say it, okay?
I want to count to
three, and at three,
you're going to have the word.
The word, okay?
It's going to happen.
It's going to happen, okay Anya?
>> Anya Creightney: I believe it.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Shall we count to three,
you and me, one, two, three?
>> Anya Creightney: Let's do it.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And then
we hit three, you guys just shout
out that word, one word, okay?
One, two, three.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Anya Creightney: What
were the words, Juan Felipe?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That was good.
Okay, now let's do another one.
See you have number two.
You have that word, and
now another one, okay?
One, two, three.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Okay, that's your second word, now.
Let's do your third one, okay?
One, two, three.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Beautiful.
So let's have a volunteer that
can tell us their three words.
A volunteer, just tell
us your three words.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Car?
>> Fort?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Fort.
>> Sports.
>> Anya Creightney: Sports.
>> Car, sports --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Oh, sports.
Okay, car, sports, and wife?
>> White.
>> Anya Creightney: White.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Car, sports, white.
Oooh, good.
That's good.
Okay, National Youth Poets.
Let's give the National Youth
Poets a big hand right there.
Stand up.
[ Applause ]
And car, what?
Car, white?
Car, white, sports --
>> Anya Creightney:
Car, sport, and white.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Okay, so National Youth Poet,
I want you to write a poem titled --
>> Anya Creightney:
Car, sport, white.
A white car sport.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay,
you can use the word car, white,
and sports in the title, okay?
Okay? One, two, three, okay?
Okay, and five minutes --
three minutes from now, okay?
Three minutes, okay?
Okay, good.
Okay, it's in process.
>> Anya Creightney: In process.
It's cooking.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Very good, okay?
Okay.
>> Anya Creightney: Okay, with
the little time we have left,
Juan Felipe, I want you to
tell me what you took away
from your time as Laureate.
What do you want to move forward?
How do you want to move forward
with all that you've learned?
All the community that you've built?
The people that you've met,
the stories that you've heard?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Well, you
know, I received a lot of affection,
a lot of affection, a lot of
tenderness, a lot of sincerity,
a lot of giving, giving,
giving everywhere I went.
People just gave and gave
and gave and gave to me,
themselves to me, believed in me.
I encouraged them highly.
Told me their stories, or just stood
up and just stood there in front
of me, and that's it,
and I saw them.
I stood with them, and
that was it, in many ways.
Whether it was an Silver City
up in the mountains in Mexico,
or whether it was in South
Florida, and St. Petersburg,
where people were dancing a
jitterbug at the hotel, and on.
So I was filled with -- I'm filled
with their lives and their feelings,
and all the challenges that they're
facing, and again, once again,
a lot of issues about
immigration and migration
and the youth, very
nervous about it.
The youth are feeling a lot, all
these things that we're feeling.
They're feeling them tenfold.
Not just the way you and I feel
them, but tenfold, because they're
so young and so sensitive, and they
really a pay attention to all it.
They're very interested in all
of it and concerned about it.
Issues of war and peace, issues
of what's going on in the street
and the brutality that's
taking place, the violence,
and issues from the government
that they don't agree with,
that they feel are against them.
So they're very concerned
about that.
They were very difficult stories.
So I walked away with
inspiration, and I walked away
with a greater concern and
belief, and believing more,
when human beings, and wondering
how we can all survive and how
to assist them, and what
can I do as a writer?
And what can I do as a good
old-fashioned human being
without the writing,
without the books?
And it's almost like this.
When I listen to the youth poets
here, and when I meet you here,
I know that you all have big
hearts, and you all are doing things
for others, and you all love
language, knowledge, cultures,
and you all are very inclusive.
I've got a feeling that's who you
are, and I also have a feeling
that you want to do something
about what's taking place,
and that's why you're here also,
even though it doesn't
say it upon the wall.
So that's where I'm
at, in meeting you,
in meeting all, with more to give.
I want to find out
what that is, you know?
I don't want to be
angry, but you know what?
I got a little angry,
and you know what?
I wrote that -- I didn't
write angry,
but I wrote very direct poetry.
I had to say things, and I
said them, and I got that book
in the hotel, and I was
filling with it this morning.
That's one way, and the
other way is to be joyful.
You have to bring both
poles together.
The concerns for our
communities and for ourselves
and for what's taking place
in our nation, and our joy.
We cannot let go of our joy
and just keep the fire burning.
We need the fountains of our
joy, and we need the fire, too.
So then the question is
putting them together
without extinguishing
any one of them.
So that we have the passion,
the boldness, the honesty,
the truth speaking and truth
writing, and truth being,
and we have the embrace and the
tenderness and the kindness.
That's our challenge right now.
Because we can do one and burn up.
We can do the other and recede and,
perhaps, become silent and perhaps,
both of those are okay, but I think
if you do both, you will solve --
we'll create -- we'll
have a better answer,
a new example that we
have not had before.
So we need a new example.
We can't do things the way
we did them five decades ago,
where I started.
We cannot do things the way
they're being done now, perhaps.
Because they're very
brutal right now.
We have to do things in a new way.
So maybe it's a new kind of
writing, and maybe it's a new kind
of speaking, and a
new kind of gathering.
There has to be a gathering.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah, I agree.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
There has to be a gathering.
>> Anya Creightney: That's lovely.
What's better than that?
What a great lesson to
of learned, Juan Felipe.
The biggest of all.
Well, I'm afraid our time is
up, but I want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart.
You're an absolute joy.
Please everyone, Juan Felipe.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Thank you, Rob.
Thank you, Anne.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.